the arcade this is the koala wear pink
cat
alright ladies and gentlemen it's five
o'clock p.m. welcome to the second
biannual I think that's the word retro
game roadshow at PAX Prime so basically
I am a big fan of trashy reality
television like pawn stars and american
pickers and storage wars and auction
hunters and basically if it involves
people finding collectibles and talking
about how much they're worth i will sit
there and watch that show and i thought
let's do that with people's video games
and so basically what how it's going to
work is we've talked to a whole lot of
you many of you here in the audience
have brought some really i mean looking
down the list some pretty cool gaming
collectibles so you're going to come up
then you're going to sit right here with
us you get to be on a pax panel for a
few brief moments and you get to sit
next to frank's defaulting from your
wandering hands just slap muy say no
Frank and and what he will do is he will
use his web camera on his computer and
so the entire rest of you in the
audience would be able to see the
collectible and this this panel of
experts here will we will talk about
what it is why it's cool why it's
collectible why it's rare or why it's
not rare at all and we will attempt to
hazard a guess at how much it is worth
or how much you might get for it should
you decide to sell it I really do want
to stress that these these prices this
is for entertainment purposes only do
not try to like take out insurance on
these things and be like some guy at a
convention about web comics told me that
it was worth X amount of money like
we're going to do our we're going to do
our damnedest but please if you really
have you know if you really want to go
and get things appraised this is for
entertainment purposes only thank you I
am now fully absolved all legal
liability in other words we're guessing
sometimes sometimes we're just guessing
we will do our absolute damndest to
guess correctly so uh we are going to
start so anyway so actually so okay so
hold on I did where start just just to
be really um to be clear to sitting to
to my left your right is is is Frank's
if all d who is a who is kind of a
genius he is very very smart about the
history of video games has a very
extensive collection of video game
magazines and writes all sorts of very
well researched pieces on the history of
games and that is him now applied for
him
I don't work for one up anymore oh boy
you you do freelance for one up okay no
no I switched him it used to say one up
and lost levels and I moved lost levels
to the top oh I'm sorry excuse me i'm
selling Frank short Frank is Frank is a
video gaming archaeologist and he is he
is he has participated in or spearheaded
the saving or creating of many dozens of
prototype video games and making sure
that when copies when prototypes of
unreleased video games are found that
they are dumped in that they're released
to the world at large and now I'm poor
should have sold some of them yeah I'm
sitting to sitting to your left my right
is a person whose video game collection
dwarfs all of your video game
collections he has an entire basement in
his house full of amazing things and is
it also an expert in his own right and
he's working well he's the director of
development did other ocean interactive
or something like that pretty much he is
a he is a big big cheese at other ocean
interactive they're doing war of the
worlds which is out on the show floor
think it looks really cool and also an
extremely knowledgeable person Mike
Micah thank
i'm chris kohler i have spent way too
much money on old video games I'm not
proud so anyway let's let's start the
show let us start the retro game
roadshow and one of the first names we
have on the list must have been one of
the first people in line so he seems to
be very excited to be here brandon s
where's brandon s there he is yeah there
he is Brandon didn't come up here and
take a seat show everyone how it's done
be the role model for this room of
bright eyed youngsters hi Brandon hi
hello we got here what's up we have a
copy of panic restaurant for the NES
let's switch over into the unicorn cam
okay set this up somehow Brendan once
you tell us about panic restaurant and
how you came across this cartridge well
I went to a church garage sale and they
were selling an NES for 50 bucks with
like 20 games and I mean most of them
were like super mario con i think i
ended up with like four copies of that
she bought the whole thing yeah i bought
the whole thing okay all dreams and one
of the games in there was panic
restaurant and i had tried to do
research on it but i couldn't really
find that much information on it and i'd
gone to flea markets and game stores and
stuff but nobody really seemed to have a
copy so i'm not too sure about the game
yep I know how much it's worth yeah so
you know collecting the nintendo
entertainment system is becoming very
popular now has a lot of the kids who
grew up with the nes start turning well
over 30 in my case and start getting a
little bit more money and start thinking
like okay i want to go back and buy all
these things that I had as a kid or in
the case of really panic restaurant
didn't have as a kid a lot of people
will tell you I mean panic restaurant it
is a late release nes game it came out
very very
late in the NES is life it's a popular
game is by taito it's a really fun
arcade style game a little freaky and so
basically panic restaurant several other
games like bubble bobble part 2 and the
second Flintstones game called surprise
at dinosaur peak a lot of people say
that these these games actually were
only ever made available to rental
stores like not a lot of stores even
wanted to stock nes anymore so let a
video rental place I mean keep in mind i
think i think this one's lay 93 exactly
the super nintendo had been out for ya
years Senate the nintendo was just like
what you got a few were eight years old
and your mom's poor you know uh-huh but
there was all that time at that time but
there was still but there was still a
thriving you know rental market so a lot
of these goes mostly made it there so
panic restaurant is it's not so Bubble
Bobble to which was released around the
same time for the fact that it's a
bubble bobble game is actually worth a
little bit more than then panic
restaurant if you had just the cartridge
of bubble bobble to it's like well over
a hundred dollars it's like a 100 to 125
cartridge to have the whole set have the
box and the instruction manual and the
important thing to realize is they were
rental games in many cases so the
instruction manuals get destroyed by
little kids whose mom was poor thank you
Frank and and and and oftentimes the box
would sit in a blockbuster video and get
Sun faded so I mean the condition of the
box and manual really affects it but a
cartridge only copy of panic restaurant
you know if you were to basically want
to sell this to somebody would really
get between like 80 and a hundred
dollars yeah it is one of the rare like
officially licensed Nintendo games it is
and I'll tell you it's going up that
used to be something about maybe fifty
to sixty dollar cartridge and if you had
the Box in the instructions you'll be
looking a little over a hundred yeah and
now complete sets of panic restaurant
with the box with the instructions are
trending towards 200 and the game the
cartridge itself is going up the thing
about classic Nintendo games like you
said it's kind of
coming in vogue to collect NES games
right now and when people start that
they you know eventually try to complete
the set because that's just where you go
when you start and panic restaurant
tends to be you know of the seven
hundred plus games tends to be you know
one of the last ten to twenty that
people need and so you know when you get
that desperate and like you said you
couldn't even find another copy yeah
when looking around so so when you get
that desperate to start filling in those
last few you know you're it's just the
those handful of people who are who are
only half those few left or just bidding
against each other like crazy yeah
they've already spent thousands of
dollars to get that far they're not
gonna let this game stop them from
that's why Stadium events which is
everyone's last one which no one brought
as far as hi oh you know you you're
speaking of crappy reality shows earlier
and what was the one that the guy found
in Nintendo he's like oh this is worth
14 thousand dollars yeah yeah no Stadium
events the game that was in a lot they
went on ebay drove a lot to fourteen
thousand dollars cuz it's it's the
rarest one yes not worth 14,000 done
it's not however it is you gotta make
twenty dollars for the whole set hey we
got 5050 you still got a very good deal
yeah I would pay that any day for for
for that alright you thank you thank you
very much friend
gonna you know actually speaking of
which so speaking of which talking about
like you know do you have do you have
games in your attic that are worth a
whole bunch of money you know one of the
things that's really kind of taking off
right now are are the NES sorry that was
another thing i'm not going to do our
black box nes games and this is
referring to the very first games that
nintendo brought out for the nintendo
entertainment system when it came into
America they all have a very similar box
design with a pixel art and there's
there's basically 30 of them the the
caveat here and when I say that these
are going up in value is that the value
is in the box and the value is in the
condition of the box if you have a copy
of Donkey Kong jr. math up in your attic
and you know I'm sure that a lot of
misguided parents did in fact think that
Apes were the perfect tutor for
therefore they're struggling children um
if you've got the cartridge you can get
a cool ten dollars for it any day of the
week but because a lot of kids threw
away these boxes because these are the
oldest nes games in the boxes just got
destroyed because Nintendo did wise up
and not make a whole lot of copies of
Donkey Kong jr. math you know the last
and I'm actually selling it short on
this slide the last you know mint in box
copy of this game on ebay sold for about
six hundred and fifty dollars with the
that's what that's with a really nice
box and the instruction manual and the
game I saw online for 30 in in the box
yeah Wow when was wasn't what is this in
like 2002 exactly so I mean they sings
go up yes that isn't it and I'm not
saying that the prices of NES games are
going to go up forever you know I mean
it's they're going to go up there going
to go higher than they are now and at
some point you know they are going to
come back down it happened with Atari I
mean the prices of a lot of like you
know complete in box Atari 2600 stuff
you know was going up and then it all
kind of came down because you have a
limited number of people who are looking
to get this whole set of games and once
they all have it
no demand drops away you know people
complain about the 3ds launch this is a
launch title no the NES but it's real
but it's so important is I know anyone
Mike you had said that you still
possibly somewhere in your parents place
is your old copy of this oh yeah I just
went back literally a couple weeks ago
and found all these like I my dad was
one of those guys who threw away all of
his stuff and he was a kid so when the
NES came through he's just like hold on
the stuff he kept all the boxes up in
the attic for us so when I went back all
these games have their boxes except
manuals it was awesome and I have like
two copies of stack up that I didn't
really hold yeah I know you want one
Chris I know I actually I already I got
one but yeah a lot of ways leading us on
to the stack up thank you very much that
way hey nice um you know stack up was a
game for the robotic operating buddy the
Rob and it required extra parts and so
it was packaged in a very big box that
had you know different claws for the
robot and little discs that he picked up
and put down and if you have that whole
thing you know now you're again you're
looking at a set that's worth like you
know between 350 and 400 dollars right
now because collectors needed they want
the whole thing and the condition of the
box is very important these black boxes
the way that they made them as soon as
they start taking a little bit of damage
the black ink starts to chip off of them
and so what collectors are really
looking for is they're looking for
something that's in really really nice
shape when this box in particular is
tough because it's bigger to house all
the stuff so just you know a little bit
of weight on it it causes a lot of
creases in it very true yep hard to find
a really nice one yep and so again if
you've got these old NES games to
everything right it might be a good time
to go find them you know not necessarily
sell them but get them out of the attic
and and get them into sacred spiders out
yeah and then where am I maintain its
jeremiah and stack up in particular a
lot of you might actually have the game
you might be missing the parts those
parts actually pretty easy to get it is
the box that's the hardest thing to have
yeah the parts you can go to places even
like for jsf online they have hundreds
of brand new parts partisans yep yep so
and again some of the other games that
are coming up like urban champion
balloon fight clue cool and I mean these
are games that are rising in value as
people
start to get into I'm gonna collect
black box games the next you know games
like like like soccer that I think I
isn't down there but uh you know I can't
I can't find it personally like I've
been checking to see if i can get a
complete copy of soccer for the NES
cannot find one and so basically you
know even things that you know there was
no demand for them they're starting to
come up because this Frank said
collectors are starting to try to
collect complete sets of whatever it is
and so yeah so anyway um on let's keep
going here Matthew M can Matthew M
please come up please welcome him today
after Matthew is going to be Bill and
Bill em you're on deck just be ready so
I'm saying what is this yeah what's in
this that's a sealed copy of final
fantasy 3 for this in es signed by Nobuo
Uematsu the composer and here's 10 and
also we finally see one ya doin security
and I have photos on this thumb drive
that proved that it was actually nice
tasty everybody gone away to contesta I
know I'd love to yeah I might be a
little too uh I'm not gonna load that's
yeah yeah yeah just in case those but
you know what and and the important
thing is what you just mentioned is it's
so important that you have you know
Providence essentially you you can prove
that somebody didn't just scribble on
your sealed copy of final fantasy 3
right so to have that photograph there
is very important especially when you're
dealing with signed collectibles and it
does look kind of scribbly to me though
there ya know I'm obviously and again
I've seen you a monster signature that
looks pretty good to me i'm not a
signature authenticated are going to
wipe off my potentially sweaty hands
before you touch any of these so let you
know it is uh there's been a lot of
research done in two
to authenticate a sealed nes game yes
that looks legit to me okay yeah let's
let's let's take this opportunity and
look at the seal I mean I don't want to
encourage you guys to try to recreate
this at home or people but it's pretty
difficult but and licensed nes game will
always have a seal going this way across
it back if you go up and down someone's
ripping you off and if there's nothing
someone's probably ripping you off and
then this is this is a pretty distinct
yeah that either way that that folds
over like that way the shrink wrap folds
over i mean that's that's how you know
it's like from the factory Super
Nintendo I mean you know you're gonna
look a lot of Super Nintendo games are
gonna have a hang tab on the back of the
box but that doesn't necessarily mean
anything because if you're going to go
through all the trouble of faking a
sealed Super Nintendo game you can stick
a hang tag on there but if you're gonna
fake it you do a better job yeah and
again Super Nintendo games that's what
they want you to think so super nintendo
games have vertical seam going up and
down the back so as far as our scene
panel of experts is concerned mike did
you take a look at these already yeah i
did you know any injustice super nes
this is something like I mean everybody
out here you'd an odd when you saw this
like anybody have a guess what they
think this is where I like I care what
people think this is worth we have a lot
I hear a lawyer for about Yeager i think
a lot good I mean well first of all
let's let's let's let's take the
signature up let's not yet so yeah I'm
gonna really make signature off but but
let's pretend that
we fixed it for you let's pretend that
the signature was not on this yeah i
mean so final fantasy there were
actually a lot of sealed copies of this
very very like you could walk into kb
toy stores and you could still buy final
fantasy like even like in the nintendo
64 days yeah i mean they this is a game
that was reprinted it was like they kept
copies in circulation I think they
reprinted it after the Super Nintendo
versions came out if I'm namaste oh ok
yes I could see that happen on but I
don't think there's any difference
between the original run or anything so
I don't think you know but it's still
you know its final fantasy for for God's
sake right it is a series that despite
best efforts on the part of Square Enix
to make people I don't NC 13 it's still
going strong and so you know the fact
that you've got the very first one still
sealed you know this is I mean probably
this game I think the high end would be
like 200 bucks for a sealed Final
Fantasy 1 yeah I would agree yeah yes
that's probably where it would top out
and final fantasy 3 you know again what
it has over Final Fantasy 1 is that
people love it you know a lot more right
so I mean you have more people out there
looking to get it seal games are is
tough because the people who collect
sealed games they they're really all
about condition you know they've got to
haven't you noticed be I mean they're
collecting sealed games they want
something that's like just totally
factory you yeah so there's a company
the grades sealed games based on their
sealed condition oh yeah yeah just like
just like how you'll see comic books
that are better graded you know there's
a company that really does have a tiny
little tear here and and that's the kind
of thing that would that would you know
knock it down right so um you know final
fantasy 3 i would i would go again no
signature probably north of 200 for that
probably not by much further north
really i think i'd go three yeah yeah
okay probably between two and three yeah
obviously three as well this is and it's
going to be going up yeah both of these
games actually gonna like it finally she
is topping out a little bit but final
fantasy 3 is definitely going out like
in there's the last year we've seen some
sell for upwards or like three
yeah okay so now we come to the
signature you know one of a kind items
the problem with them is their one of a
kind and you really can't you can't
figure out exactly how much they're
going to go for but to the right person
you know because it's I've seen sign
things that are signed by people on the
development team and nobody has any idea
who they are you know so but if you if
you visit love Final Fantasy enough to
buy a sealed copy of a game you know who
II masu is exactly and so because it's
so rare that you would get his signature
on stuff like that you know it would
send those prices a little bit higher
you know but you you might put those on
ebay and have two collectors who just
desperately want that fight over you
know we sold we um for a charity event
that I'm on the board of we got Toru
Iwatani signature on a copy of pac-man
and that was all that all but directly
the child's play basically but it went
up to six hundred dollars so again you
know these bees you know to the right
bitter would be worth a premium over the
200 300 but you've got some really
really really interesting items there
yeah and I don't think I've ever
actually seen anyone trying to sell a
signed final fantasy game before so yeah
you know this these are definitely
unique and selling them both as a set
with signature would probably I wouldn't
even do that why are you walking on our
do you even want to sell these I have no
intention oh yeah yeah no I mean you
know I'm saying this as far as the
general and I do a flawed usurper yes if
we're not selling them at all but um you
know as a general point here if you if
you were to have these and if you were
to want to sell them I would recommend
totally against selling them as a set
okay cuz I agree what you want is for
you know it's somebody's budgets only
going to go so high right so you want to
separate people to pay you a little bit
more each yeah the recommended but
there's the signatures what I'm thinking
about there's potentially I'd like oh
it's fine you probably get more money
individually right a signature scent
yeah yeah in many cases a collection can
be worth less than the sum of its parts
it's it's always better to try to you
know sell things individually
essentially and you know my personal
advice viewer to sell either one of
these
to get them graded by that company first
because I you know I think that would be
the kind of I there 04 is a grated
sealed signed the problem is they don't
do signature rating yeah they don't
count all signatures that the vga the
video game authority to count all
signatures is like a flaw on the package
so don't get these but you can go on to
the video game authority and you can
actually buy like the really really nice
like you should like these fences yeah
my hands should not have touched yeah I
would actually go and do that you can
get those for like twenty to thirty
bucks they'll make you custom cases and
then you put it in there and then you
never have to worry about any condition
and altering it chris kohler order yeah
exactly thank you very much that was
awesome kill em Phil Phil in bill em o
villain it's not dry the famous
cartoonist I thought bill nye the
science guy I was gonna come on step
right up there you go now you guys don't
got here hello hello oh actually I
wanted to ask question about that last
bolt thanks for having me followed well
sit down you have a microphone you can't
even yeah thank you letting me follow
what is essentially the Camerons dad's
Porsche a video game this is not gonna
be happy no prob so we got two items
here uh oh did you I'm sorry were you uh
were you gonna say something okay yeah
all right first item I don't know if any
of you came to our Boston panel anyone
else travel like we do yeah Oh is there
we had a we had a couple games and
watches you guys might remember yes this
is our first boxed one on our show yeah
this is a boxed Game and Watch donkey
kong now show fans does anyone know what
a game in water I think maybe some of
these below okay Lily's find people uh
this is this is the first thing Nintendo
of America did for consumers in
America's before they launch the NES
they had these line of this line of Oh
guys we've been praying
it's actually probably worth more than
the actual deal well it's worth like a
hundred dollars less than it used to be
my Sarah Jane yeah even know what I'm
doing all right okay yeah I put you home
right so there you go comedy act see the
reason that the joke there didn't get
his joke is that the the game and
watches some of them were dual screen
decades before the DS I mean nerds like
us when we first saw the dsr like that's
like a game and watch at heckling him
you know you did that i was there every
life is better on this one in the 3ds
too so so uh oh i was gonna ask you if
it works but it's actually playing right
now or no if you guys i put in a battery
just for this good for you yeah um but
i'm gonna pass this off to our panel or
getting okay you want to look at the box
real quick and then i'll put it back
yeah there's a xeroxed instructions
would know and oh yeah okay all right
yeah you can start there's another item
you've got here this is once you tell us
about this uh this is a sealed original
copy I believe of the original Famicom
Zelda that's not a bigger scale well I
you know what I like 12 of them down
here it's holding up your chair what
about hell no actually i only paid like
20 bucks from japan for that so i
figured there was something wrong with
it was forfeit or something like that
but let me let me I don't know if I got
a dealer well so I'll tell you about
that we'll start with that yeah yeah why
do we have to yeah yeah Mike recently
acquired one also so long i'm gonna i'm
gonna start i'm gonna summon it I'm
gonna lie a little bit here because I
haven't really figured out all of this
yet but in 2003 Nintendo made the
famicom disk system right which was in
Japan oh nada sorry Tendo back in the
80s
we're gonna get to take other Christmas
yeah there you go no um upendo made the
famicom disk system which was a floppy
disk drive for you gonna came from not
exactly yeah but that was a relationship
seemed photocopied instructions um so uh
basically they they basically did a
floppy disk drive for the famicom and
that's this is where a lot of games like
legend of zelda kid icarus Metroid Super
Mario Brothers to the original kind of
all originated and so in 2003 like 15 or
so years after they originally released
the thing they finally actually
discontinued it and they told the
Japanese like well sorry if you bring
your disk drive into Nintendo we won't
be able to fix it anymore which means a
day and for a long time they they were
actually if you brought your busted disk
drive Nintendo's headquarters they would
actually fix it oh the big problem was
that the rubber band was that thing that
ran the system was a fail yeah yes I
really hurted around that time this is
where I'm lying a little bit because I
don't really know about the causal
connection between these two things i
was i was living in Japan and what ended
up happening was suddenly a whole bunch
of famicom disk system games started
appearing in all of the retro game
stores for not very much money for about
10 bucks each brand new copies of The
Legend of Zelda Super Mario Brothers
Metroid kid icarus you know most of the
major first party games start showing up
in the store and this does happen you
know sometimes in the collectors world
you know you'll have a game that's
extremely rare yep sought after in all
of a sudden fun someone will just find a
pallet of them in a warehouse yes and
they're not as rare anymore yep and so
what happened is a lot of these in the
the the the early 2000s just sort of
started appearing in sores and so if
anybody was speculating and holding on
to these games for a long time you know
they might have they would probably have
seen the value decrease because you're
right you paid about 20 bucks yeah it's
probably worth between twenty and forty
dollars maybe on the app's idea how
wasn't quite as a Chinese our orders
there are a lot of them out there knows
every budget um the way you can tell
that it's still brand new is the seal
right here they're not shrink wrapped
but they have stickers on them and oh
the question I had about the previous
thing doesn't matter that i mean i'm
totally taking this off topic does it
matter if something is signed if it's
signed on the plastic shrink wrap like
his item was
or is it worth more if it's actually
signed on the actual a cardboard well I
was a really good question you know that
doors not like okay I that Justin I
thought of there's not like a reliable
tracking method for sign video games yet
at this point but it's a sign on the box
it's opened and so you got people who
freak out about that's a good point yeah
sealed is new yeah speaking of
signatures Mike brought in something
else related oh yeah i'm just gonna show
off which is the Game Boy Advance
version of this signed by miyamoto so
that's what these things you can find in
the most unlikely of places like I was
just actually in Michigan and a friend
of mine happened to just pick these up
someplace there at the single shined
Miyamoto what yeah what and he gave them
to me what don't tell him everybody
people need to get this shitty together
so as far as so as far as donkey kong
goes um so again I for the sake of
appraisal we got the original box yeah
we'll have the original instructions we
have a photocopier construction yeah
there is no warning card with this very
distressed guy and we have a pretty Sun
faded you know kind of beat-up box it's
all an act which is good you know
there's cars are falling all off of it
but at the same time Donkey Kong is
pretty much the most common of the game
and watches the the actual unit itself
is pretty well played it's very
scratched as long as much yes yeah it
seems some love yeah you do have the box
but again when we start getting into
those collectors who want the box and
want the instructions and everything
they they're looking for condition you
know now they're now they're really
getting into I want the nicest and so
you'd probably be able you know this is
you know it's probably like 40 bucks or
so unfortunately yeah okay a good
condition loose Donkey Kong about 80 if
it's really good condition this one's
not quite so the box is kind of beat up
and yeah that's the hard part is it'll
probably with the box and this probably
about 80 bucks tops okay anybody's
really looking for it but the manual
being Xerox yeah i just paid yeah just
on on ebay like six months ago i paid
twenty bucks for this oh you got it was
40 bucks for the game and watch Sophia
so I was about look at that yeah no way
everybody so we on the right braid your
appraisals exactly yeah damn
I can it just told you what I paid for
it that would have been it yes I already
knew how know why don't we spend all
this time of year very much thank you
guys thank you for bringing that up
let's get uh let's get dan g get crazy
let's kick freed angie dingy is here
there's dan g ng dizzy we got some kind
of crappy second it's off the floor here
you go Stowe's you people you people in
your video game well i got one of these
under my chair too all right i don't i
have a question Dan did you just buy
this huh yep about four hours ago okay
all right now did you buy it from the
stop and save no i did not i got of that
pink gorilla games over here here at
here packs okay cool well it's a stop
and save on it okay that's pretty great
yeah purchase debt apparently so suck it
yeah so we talked before the panel and
you said that a reason you brought this
up was because you weren't sure if it
was authentic I just wanted to confirm
the authenticity so yeah so uh and
basically I don't even off the CD is in
there you know yeah oh well first of all
one's good sign certainly yeah first of
all we should talk a little bit about
the game let's talk about this game it's
pretty good you should open up and play
it alright so this was a very late
release for the saturn right there's
like the big three right yeah there's
this and what house there's a dead
there's burning Rangers yep yep they're
shining force 3 right yeah and then
there's and then there's magic knight
rayearth towards the very very end of
the light of the short sad life span
which meant they had very limited runs
like our leader stories as well like
these were not as big some yeah they
didn't really they didn't make very many
of these as the point there were there
the saturn market was pretty much dead
you know I was I was on to always under
the impression that they were just like
well we shouldn't just not release this
not gonna make money off of it but we
might as well just print what we have
right so they drain a couple yeah and
this was a really very brilliant
forward-thinking game it was in a
role-playing game based on the Panzer
Dragoon series of shooters in which he
wrote around but a dragon and it
combined you know RPG elements with you
know like the in-flight combat on
dragons and it was great it was so good
and they didn't make very many of them
so you know and and do you guys need a
closer look at the seals i think i'm
good i can see it i'll show it to mike
though it had three discs correct it was
three discs were yep it was four discs
it's a lot of game yeah if you were to
open it up not that I'm suggesting the
video so but because we see there the
discs in there like in like cardboard
holders you know it was very it was kind
of a cheaply made set that came over the
eighth you've ever looked like ten cents
yeah yeah they got that gooey crap in
the middle ap oh good yeah uh my my my
feeling first of all is that I really
trust the buyer that you got this from
pink gorilla that raspberry you learn
yeah um you know that that's an
important part of collecting disease you
know know your dealer very important
life lesson yeah um that was one of the
motivations because it was here at pax
yeah I mean those guys are not gonna
they're not gonna lie to you then I can
screw you over um the the the the stop
and save sticker on here if this were
somehow a fake this would be a brilliant
fake cuz that is awesome yeah it's
pretty nice the seals to me look like
they came from a factory this isn't like
I mean you know I don't know how much
detail you can see on that but you know
this isn't like someone at the video
store using their shrink wrap with the
heat gun in the back rooms right do you
know this is this is a factory seal and
I don't really know if you can see from
the on the camera but it has the hang
tab on the back as well
so I mean you know again this for
entertainment purposes only prick CIL's
but I would call this authentic
absolutely i have to dallas yeah i have
no doubt about it authentic city as far
as value should we go the Antiques
Roadshow route and asked what he paid or
should I would yeah well I mean if you
don't mind saying I don't mind I mean I
didn't didn't bother me I wanted to make
sure yeah cuz I was looking for this
game well sounded like you were just
willing to pay what yeah yeah I paid 500
for it mhm that's uh I'd say that's
market value for someone like pink
gorilla and they obviously know what
they have there a retailer YUM they know
what I'm sitting on yeah you know I
would say that that's that's a fair
price but i would say on ebay it's
probably more in the 350 to 450 range
that didn't bother me to me yeah I mean
you paid a slight markup but it doesn't
matter and you also got to see the
condition first hand and si it I wanted
a rare classic game I mean you know put
that away and very long time just leave
it alone yeah yep good for you good for
you can get it all from and played it
you haven't you still get played yeah no
not me alright show hands for opening
huh all right they seen you on they have
voted and again um you know if you're I
mean you're looking to protect your
investment essentially yeah I mean you
know get a invest in a box again video
game 40 um I don't try to remove this by
the way oh yeah you keep it all intact
yeah I've keep the price tag on there
where can I find that case um how can I
go about its the company's called the
company is called video game authority
or vta getting that right so these are
the guys we mentioned earlier they will
grade games yeah and I don't think she'd
bother getting this great I think you
should I think should get that grated
yep the the problem is you know they're
gonna see you're gonna see that sticker
and they're going to mark down the grade
that the game is whereas I think most
buyers would actually prefer to have
that sticker on there yeah but what
they're going to do is they're gonna
they're going to grade it this is the
really important thing they're going to
grade this game and they are going to
they're going to examine that seal not
for entertainment purposes
but they really will examine that
ceiling will make absolutely sure that
that is an authentic seal and what they
do is they put it inside that lucite box
and that gets closed up and so basically
you as the as the the investor
essentially in anybody who is might be
the buyer later on is going to know that
that that seal is definitely authentic
and that just as long as that box hasn't
been open and I mean even if you don't
plan on getting rid of it it's good too
except protect your investment get it
graded immediately because all that's
going to happen is if you hold on to it
in a box there's always the potential
that it's going to get damaged and so to
get this thing what you want to do is
get it graded because when they grade it
they put it inside of a very thick
lucite container that you can then
display on the shelf or whatever it is
you want to do with it but it gets
sealed up and that's you know it's gonna
maintain its like in this case like you
have no plans of opening it there's no
reason not to protect it you know
something we should point out is that
there is a small crack yeah and again
vga to the table like being you for that
but you know you you're not don't don't
be too concerned about what number great
they put on it you know the point is you
wanted a seal panzer dragon dragon saga
you got one you've achieved it you go
boy
thank you very much sir appreciate it
let's let's get alex f up here because
he's going to stump us all and i know
what he has i'm looking at this thing
and we were all very much everybody I'll
except here it comes to make us all look
like fools oh the sound damn it Mike go
right over there yeah okay okay yeah all
right I bet very few of you have ever
seen one of these before this predates
the Gameboy by about five years this is
Anna marks an epoch game pocket computer
this is a technically it's not the first
portable game system with removable
cartridges but uh I think it's the first
one with like ROM cartridges as opposed
to having the game sort of built into a
screen and whoa that was a micro vision
vision head up yeah card okay um that's
just a dummy card in there right now
okay so you actually brought a cartridge
also does this uh this is gonna boot up
yeah it works hey all right here we go
bonus for everyone we get to see you
going hey guys aren't sound
yeah all right let's uh let's put that
cartridge in here how do we do that so
do i watch your show us okay kurtis kool
cycles in there all right I kind of like
how its gothics clear things you can
actually see the cuts guys are rules in
it too oh yeah wow geez wow that's a
that's an evasion that's that's
basically a double screen just the one
screen is static yeah the contrast okay
can you guys yeah it's it's primitive
well Robin sound like graphics are
amazing it gives you the resolution or
in the front door hey no just no just
don't move all right all right okay
don't try and be so oh god it's so good
bond ah so so much my understanding of
this and I see this all the time when I
go to like Akihabara and this is a
japan-only device and yes it is a very
very early you know predecessor to the
to the Game Boy it's big clearly
certainly the first Japanese portable go
get my fine yeah yep yeah this made by
epoch epic yeah i think is an EP OCH oh
this is that pronounced epic yeah you
know that's what we always say but the
head went six games said 445 E five
games but and you're probably more of an
expert on this than even we are because
the game that you have would you say
that don't please please tell us what
you have here yeah it's it's a box with
instructions of storekeepers which is
like the very last game they're really
released for and I apparently it's very
very rare I found out about this system
on the retro knots about all the non
Nintendo handhelds and I merely went to
ebay and found this oh no there goes
yeah like two years to find an auction
with that in it or one did you get us
did you get this on American ebay oh my
god a yahoo japan okay i saw a loose
copy of that with a loose system go on
ebay twice and they went for over four
hundred dollars each time okay yep and I
wasn't willing to pay that but I managed
to find that on with a broken system
with the box oh I didn't have a box with
this one so I have a box well you didn't
bring the box today okay too big um and
i paid about religion how big is it um
well it's not that much Barry it's just
like foam over top and I guys fight so
what did you pay for the is 130 we're
after like the like the double shipping
had to go to a third party yeah yeah
yeahs cuffs and like the wire transfer
fee in the terrible yen conversion rate
I've been there yeah so I'm sorry 130 I
just brought another auction to get two
more of the games i'm only missing one
now oh damn great so what inspired you
to start collecting the system um I
collect handheld I have about 50
different ones and i found out it
existed so my guy want that there's a
band are you aware of crisco bells
webpage yes and that's like everything I
know open eyes yeah everything I know
about the system is from that web page
so actually used his website to try and
like to get the Japanese like text to
try and search on who Japan behind oh
okay yep hmm I mean the batter who
bought these at open auction does give
us a bit of a clue as you know I'm sure
that the the Japanese collectors were
hunting the same auction that you did
and we're looking to yeah I just really
wanted this one because they like Socko
been games have always loved them i
remember playing one of the versions on
my grandpa's 286 when i was a kid and I
just loved it so yeah that's pretty much
for every system right sokoban which is
the game where you have to this theory
or the warehouse guy and you have to
push all the boxes around to get to the
exit yeah the evil horrible game for
people who hate themselves yeah yeah so
uh you know I I'm gonna have to admit
ignorance on monetary value for this
particular lot it's just a rare e-except
oh yeah just need to just answer the you
say the auction and who want a 234 this
game and a broken one and a broken
system you add an extra game it was the
raversi which seems like it's the mo
common game so so basically what we know
that is but we can be pretty sure of is
that the price that you paid is probably
for that game you know like the people
anybody who's going to be buying that
game they probably already have a system
they don't need a broken one they
probably already have reversi right so
so in Japan or on a Japanese auction you
can figure that's a yeah about a hundred
and thirty bucks right and that's for
the rarest and that's the last run game
so you know that's probably the high
price on that considering these other
games yep it's a very good vintage yeah
the batteries bring it down mo chedda
you have the battery i've seen some
people with like the original bad or
reason like that with all the inserts
yeah chase and everything I don't know
how much they paid but I've seen some
people with that stuff it sounds
dangerous so uh you guys have any
opinion you know Ellie just in general
to say that bringing things back from
Japan to the US will very often increase
their value because the the supply here
of Japanese video games is so much lower
I mean because right now this is
increasing value because of awareness
suddenly there's probably a lot of
people out there like oh yeah because
yeah there's a lot more like books and
websites and things devoted to obscurity
I mean how many people right now are on
ebay looking for a game pocket well one
thing I mean how many people have ever
considered putt potentially before this
panel buying a game pocket computer by
by epic I see one hand okay so basically
what this then there's another guy so
basically what that tells you is you
know the demand for this is actually
there's just a couple of options like a
couple months ago a loose one went for
200 in a box went went for 160 like one
couple weeks laters yeah gonna get a
secret sunny but there are handheld
collectors out there you know there's a
lot of guys like you who just love
collecting all manner of handheld video
gaming systems so that's actually good
because eventually they get everything
that come out of America's they have to
start going into other territories so
you know it is it is definitely a it's
it's own kind of interesting subcategory
of collecting but in the end it's a few
people kind of fighting over a few
things but it is a really cool piece and
we appreciate you bringing up here so
thank you thanks
um we have sorry I think Blake okay
who's who's Blake Blake Fletcher Blake
Fisher oh yeah yeah blank Fisher why
don't you come up yep now we've known
Blake for a while and he's been
collecting for a very long time as a
good friend of ours and we asked him
early on like well what do you have with
some crazy things you have that maybe
some people here haven't even seen
before and he happens to have a lot of
things that people have seen is our box
five and a quarter nobody's seen this
that's probably that is probably true so
high density Blake Blake is a Blake is a
collector and we didn't really want to
appraise this stuff so much is just kind
of show it off cuz I like looking at
cooled crap and I would imagine you guys
do too so no horses that no one was see
cool nobody would see could bring out
more zelda dis more sealed final fantasy
all right you want to tell us what this
first one this is actually I picked up
another collection who the guy picked
these up in a Silicon Valley surplus
store and they are Atari 2600 review
roms that were shipped out to reviewers
that's what the red dot means I believe
that there's different versions of roms
out there and they have different
colored dots and I think the red ones
are review and you haven't tried these
yet one of them was tested before my
eeprom cart died which I haven't cleaned
so I should do that uh it's so sorry go
ahead well interesting one of them has
no label so it's kind of exciting it
could be anything and one of them says
starship to which there is a starship so
I don't know if it's a different rom or
or what happened what happen happens is
they may have actually created another
space game that was starship to a now
came out as a different name star
raiders maybe but it's different so the
way it would work is that a reviewer
would have a Atari 2600 cartridge with
kind of a blank I don't know what you
call it like a clippie it's baby from
socket you socket yeah
and you would just kind of pop these
right in there and then play the game
these are very cool and I want to know
what's on the mystery rom very badly
yeah some someday Michael hook me up
with a eeprom reader will check it out
the mail in a week so these things you
know these these are what you call kind
of high-level collect your pieces it's
really no uh this is going beyond
collecting things you find in stores and
this is collecting things you're not
even supposed to have legally so uh
we've notified Atari thanks they're
going to reclaim their property Olin is
on his way now sees the thing about
these review games and you know Chris
and I and even like it we have
professionally reviewed games you're not
supposed to keep the review cut you're
supposed to destroy or send back yeah so
for review copies from the Atari air to
survive is kind of miraculous yeah so
these are very cool pieces oh man what
else do you have I have two other things
the first this is probably my pride and
joy of my collection this is cry which
is something so many of you as far as I
know this is the only known copy in
existence of PC junior mule yeah um bc
junior was very early maybe the first
IBM home computers yeah um and obvi I
don't know how many of you have heard of
IBM how many of heard of Electronic Arts
yeah this is kind of where both those
things started but yeah go ahead and
listen so this was a so I just had my
15th year ebay anniversary according to
some email I don't know if they want me
to do but they sent me an email saying
I've been there this search went on for
12 years right when i started ebay i had
read about it on some website that pc
junior version existed is a rumor so i
just set up a search and then two years
ago there was a hit on the search for
the first time it showed up there was no
picture it was running about ninety
dollars i put a snipe in for a great
deal more and figuring that if it was
real i was going to get it ended up
buying it for three hundred dollars and
it's still the only one I've ever seen
there's a scan someone who did drop a
skin on the internet of the label that I
know is act
right now because it's the same label so
someone else has one but no one knows
who that person is and his email doesn't
work and you know that this is the kind
of item that maybe not that many people
are aware of and there might not be you
know a lot of people looking for this
but as far as you know historical
artifact of video yesterday like this is
just a beautiful piece that incredible
condition no shirt on today Rep young
hey you want to show that to the camera
yah mule my favorite game so I have
every version of mule that's been
released in the US including all the
bootlegs and then and now finally I need
to get the x68000 version of it no pc-98
pc 88 for japan let's pour Japan and now
this is the the craziest thing yeah this
is this is it that was other stuff
yeah and this is the last thing I have
so this is another search that I've been
looking for forever which is a Capcom
power system changer again I've never
seen one in the Box I saw one on ebay
for a thousand dollars loose about six
years ago and that's the only time I've
ever seen one for sale open it up check
it out yeah please this one what am i
squashing hear ya oh yeah they made
things to last back then this is mine so
this is the view good here okay like I'm
excited if nobody with the sickness so
essentially when neo geo got popular
Capcom wanted to make a neo geo in Japan
as we understand it now all my
information is second-hand because even
Capcom people have no idea what you
might recognize those ports yeah Super
Nintendo controller ports so the idea
here was that you could get roms of the
authentic arcade game so you could get
the arcade version of Street Fighter to
pop in a cartridge here and play it for
real rather than the Super Nintendo
version of it it's actually a very much
clothes modification of the CPS one
board which is a big no-no if you guys
see and they're big grey boards about
this big plastic so it would slide on
top of it but I have to this date never
seen one of these versions for this
system just the real CP so you can't
actually do anything no I can plug in a
jam aboard into it I've tested it it
works so it's like a super gun essential
it is with a weird inverted JAMA port so
you do that so
is the only like Capcom home console
yeah I would say so and so and basically
just plug that in and plug it into your
TV and put Super Nintendo controllers in
it and you're playing our games yeah you
would have been the coolest kid yeah all
those like neo geo guys are all prancing
around and they're like highfalutin ways
like this would have been awesome I had
to counter that you want to come over
and play real Street Fighter 2 yeah
what's weird is he found it in a store
completely on accident oh yeah this is a
good story so I've set up a circuit in
Akihabara I'm sure chris has as well
where you know all the stores when they
open where you're going to go this is an
arcade store that's hidden around a
corner by the Euro play star kabob which
is delicious and oh yeah okay I know
that Becca Bob little second floor
unlabeled arcade store huh and I've
brought friends to show how cool this
arcade store and i moaned about how i'm
just going to find a cps changer someday
because isn't that it on the store shelf
right there is after eight years of
looking and then it was and it was a
hundred dollars spent a steak have you
gotten offers for this no thank you boy
okay thanks blank we'll put this video
online so expect offers from my
collectors yeah thank you that was
really awesome so let's get it let's get
fur Quinn are up here we're fast running
out of time we thank you
ferc win our will be our final guests
unfortunately we are totally at a time
however if you still have stuff with you
and your kind of wondering like you know
I've got plans after this exactly we're
all will hang around for as long as we
possibly can until packs kicks us out of
whatever area we're standing in and we
will definitely talk to you so finally
is anyone in this room have D batteries
so uh Mike you saw this earlier I don't
need yeah gives a prelude mirror the
pac-man cleco tabletop and they might
not be probably not many people are
familiar with these old ok that's a
pretty good show of hands they've done a
large run of some of the classic arcade
games yet zaxxon yet pac-man there's ms
pacman frog did you the donkey kong one
or was there something there's a blue
Yamaha one yeah um these these are
initially because they they're they're
built pretty well but not great so over
time even just age causes them to kind
of fall out of working condition that's
why we're asking for the the batteries
because what will often happen is the
the array of the screen itself certain
rows or columns might actually just
stopped working and they're very hard to
repair it's almost impossible beyond
that point sometimes you can shake it
around like Fonzie and hit it on a table
and starts to work they're like
calculator screen they're basically
calculor screams with some color don't
work last time you played it all the
LEDs lit up and it's the sum of the
thing that happens that a lot of people
actually lovingly refer to as active
plaque because the activision cartridge
labels would get this like in a weird
plaque specular pattern all over it that
happens a lot on these games how's that
looking frankerz are the stickers
ourselves yeah like the actual labels
the white label will often have this
really crazy pattern on it over like
there's like acting up but it's there's
definitely you know some active plaque
on there there you go and this is a hard
thing to avoid some people have managed
to have one that survives this disease
that a lot of these things have but it's
very rare to find it so it's like it
doesn't really bring the price down that
much people just expect it to be there
it's not your fault it's not your fault
you weren't smoking around it or doing
Anna stuff it just happens um so this is
your actual childhood toy yeah that's
very cool so we know the original buyer
do know the original buyer right here do
you have the box or
manual or anything like that um no I
just I just said that's been sitting on
my shelf for a while but you did have
the battery door right Larry doors on
yeah that's great very important but a
lot of these yeah these those go missing
somehow and no real corrosion there yeah
it's not it's not gross inside there
always do that if you're going to buy
especially what you can sometimes forget
about is if you see a pong machine you
know an original like Atari home pong or
whatever in a first store and it's a
call it's ten dollars it's great and it
probably is a really good deal but the
pong machines a lot of them even though
they used AC adapters you know they also
had battery slots open it up open it
look open that I don't want to bring it
home the last one we want to do is to
open it up and it still has the original
1970s vintage batteries inside and
they've all corroded and it's disgusting
because it destroys the inside of the
machine pretty much it's it's reparable
but don't ever expect to get much for it
because that's the first thing everybody
looks at and yep Saudi values it
completely again we can't investigate
this completely but assuming it's
running really well I think I think we
kind of determined before the show in
the new 100 that's that that's about
right yet 1900 the condition it's in
with the battery case there's a lot of
people out there actually this is pretty
interesting about three years ago
somebody found a whole surplus of boxes
for just the box the box is flat not
formed earth like that so there's a
there's a chance you could actually find
that online lot people were selling I
they went is cheap as five bucks they
put the boxes together and then what's
left now is the manual looking at the
phone right yeah the phone the river
foam inside the box that's going to be
tougher I love old school uh pac-man
interpretation like the reason the
reason why this this goes for ya is
little hot dog feed and the reason why
this goes for so much is because it
looks like the arcade machine you know
it is a really cool thing I mean it was
on your shelf I mean literally like you
just had on your shelf cuz it is a just
a gorgeous little piece to finish it is
and people love these things so yeah if
you again more goal that might be in
your attic if you were a kid and you had
these in the 80s these are going for big
buckets the great condition it's you to
53 in three hours sorry a boxed in great
condition like 250 is three hundred
dollars for something like this whole
complete cycle complete is pac-man the
most valuable one no I would say
there's a good question it's probably
exacts honor the later we had some of
the people in it more obscure ones yeah
Donkey Kong is kind of hard to find too
well anyway folks we really try to meet
you all coming out here one more up for
Dom I we don't have time yeah
unfortunately but no again very sorry
that we couldn't get to you all we will
be hanging around so please do come up
and talk to us but thank you all very
very much thanks everybody